[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory in
today's video we're going to be
discussing all of the times that albus
dumbledore was in fact wrong or just had
terrible judgment i know this is a
strong stance to take at the very
beginning of a video but with the title
being what it is it surely comes as no
surprise so let's get into it
dumbledore was many things throughout
the harry potter series mentor to our
young protagonist harry hogwarts
professor turned headmaster loyal member
of the order of the phoenix a wizarding
legend in his own right he was also
quite frequently just plain wrong and if
you don't believe me let's take a look
at all the times that we know of that
albus dumbledore made decisions that
were incredibly questionable if not
altogether incorrect i've counted 25 and
i welcome your additions in the comments
below this video if you think i've
missed any the first instance of
dumbledore being in the wrong in my
opinion was when he chose to go on a
trip around the world after graduating
hogwarts with the fire stoge which would
have left his mother kendra alone to
look after his unwell younger sister
ariana and wayward brother aberforth
clearly with his father percival
imprisoned the proper thing to do would
have been to help his mother in caring
for his younger siblings not galavanting
across the globe with his mate to
celebrate his graduation
after orianna accidentally killed their
mother in an uncontrollable outburst of
magic albus had to cancel his trip with
alphaus returned to godric's hollow and
care for his younger siblings his
reaction to this was quite obscene being
that he was more bitter at having to
alter plans for his future then he was
saddened by the sudden loss of his
mother this disturbing outlook is of
course a second example of a time when
dumbledore was wrong certainly feeling
somewhat resentful would have been
understandable
but he admits to harry the deathly
hallows to being more upset to the loss
of his freedom than the loss of his
family at the time following the death
of his mother a young dumbledore formed
an intense friendship with future dark
wizard gelat grindelwald he ended up
falling in love with grindelwald and to
put faith in the radical ideologies he
presented as it turned out grindelwald
wasn't just interested in debating the
theoretical pursuit of power but was
serious about the subjugation of muggles
amongst other terrible things making it
clear that dumbledore's trust in and
feelings for grindelwald were quite
misplaced this brings us to our fourth
example of a time when dumbledore was
wrong despite having recognized
grindelwald's dangerous and
unpredictable nature albus engaged in an
argument with gelat in the presence of
his unwell sister ariana this argument
turned deadly as a stray spell ended up
killing the poor girl quite obviously it
would seem dumbledore never should have
jeopardized his family's well-being by
being so reckless with their presence
whether it was out of love or fear
dumbledore waited almost half a century
before challenging grindelwald despite
the terror gelat was wreaking on the
wizarding world as the only living
wizard powerful enough to confront
grindelwald the correct choice for
dumbledore seems to be that he should
have done so much sooner as this single
action could have saved many lives he
brought the future lord voldemort tom
riddle from wool's orphanage to hogwarts
now i'm not saying that bringing tom to
a place where he could further his
magical education was the wrong decision
what i do think was a poor choice was
leaving tom to his own devices despite
seeing a darkness in him dumbledore
could have mentored him or asked another
professor to help guide him down a
better path
instead it seems he just left him to
twirl deeper and deeper into the dark
arts
next up we have dumbledore's acceptance
that sirius black was guilty of giving
away james and lily potter's location to
lord voldemort a betrayal which led to
both of the potter's murders this is a
particularly confusing one to me as
dumbledore would have seen sirius and
james roam the halls of hogwarts
together as best mates and yet he didn't
even lift a finger to investigate
black's wrongful imprisonment poor
choice
further to number seven dumbledore chose
to believe that peter pettigrew died by
sirius's hand once again i'm not sure
how he could have just blindly accepted
that sirius would have betrayed not one
but two of his best friends all in the
same evening with little to no actual
proof as we know it was actually
pettigrew who told lord voldemort where
the potters were hiding after which he
faked his own death and framed a
devastated serious despite protests from
hagrid and minerva mcgonagall dumbledore
decided the best place to leave an
orphaned infant harry was with his witch
and wizard-hating relatives the dursleys
harry's aunt petunia and uncle vernon
then proceeded to abuse harry for the
majority of the next decade forcing him
to sleep in a cupboard under the stairs
and basically be a servant in their own
house with arabella fig keeping tabs on
a young harry from just down privet
drive dumbledore would have been aware
of the mistreatment harry was enduring
so i'm really not too sure what
dumbledore was thinking here now i love
rubius hagrid who doesn't but it was
certainly a questionable choice to have
him fetch harry from the dursleys and be
his chaperone to hogwarts
sure they made it successfully to diagon
alley and picked up all the necessary
items for school but then hagrid just
left harry unattended at king's cross
railway station with little to no
instruction on how to access the magical
platform nine and three quarters you
know the one and only way to board the
hogwarts express
surely there was someone a little more
let's say level-headed whom dumbledore
could have entrusted to pick up harry
mcgonigle perhaps or literally any other
professor so i know dumbledore knew
things about severus snape that no one
else did until the end of the series but
was that knowledge of his true nature
really enough to allow snape to be so
horrible to all the students snape was
often quick to use his sharp tongue to
verbally abuse many of the pupils at
hogwarts particularly those who weren't
in southern house in my opinion this
didn't show the best form of leadership
from headmaster dumbledore another
questionable headmaster move not
catching that professor quironus
quirrell harbored lord voldemort on the
back of his head i mean dumbledore was a
great and powerful wizard did he really
not realize that something was up with
quirky quebel pretty poor judgment on
that one i'm afraid even though he knew
the great responsibility that came with
owning a deathly hallow dumbledore chose
to give an 11 year old harry the
invisibility cloak i know i know it
rightfully belonged to him but honestly
is it ever the right decision to give a
pre-teen a magical artifact that can
help them get into more trouble he
allowed detention of first-year students
to take place in the forbidden forest
enough said on that one i think young
kids dangerous creatures clearly not the
best choice in the chamber of secrets
dumbledore despite having worked at
hogwarts for many many years has no idea
where the chamber of secrets is and he
doesn't even seem to try and look for it
i guess i can't say that he was wrong
for not knowing its location but i sure
can say he was wrong for not attempting
to find it and for not shutting down the
school to protect the students from
getting hurt from the basilisk for
reasons i still don't quite understand
he hired gilderoy lockhart i suppose you
could argue that lockhart was the only
one who wanted the defense against a
dark arts job with the exception of
snape of course but quite honestly i
think snape or even no one at all might
have been preferable to this bumbling
fool who only cared about his reputation
even if dumbledore hired him to expose
him it still wasn't a good decision
dumbledore still believing sirius black
to be guilty of crimes he didn't commit
allowed dementors onto school property
to protect the students in my opinion
this decision actually put the children
in greater danger from encounters with
the dementors even if sirius had been an
actual murderer why in merlin's beard
does dumbledore only offer the time
turner as a solution once throughout the
entire series you know to think harry
and hermione use to go back in time in
the prison of azkaban i know you can't
frequently meddle with the space-time
continuum or whatever but surely there
were a few other instances in which they
could have used it to go back in time
and save a wizard or two there are of
course many laws in place around its use
but i personally think it was wrong of
him not to have allowed anyone to use
this particular device ever again he's
wrong about alistar madai moody in the
goblet of fire as he doesn't recognize
that an imposter barty crouch jr has
used apologies potion to take his place
with all his years of experience you'd
think dumbledore would have noticed that
something was little off don't you a
little bit embarrassing if you ask me
dumbledore allowed an underage harry to
participate in the triwizard tournament
initially and wrongfully questioning
whether harry vented his own name
dangerous tournament plus unqualified 14
year old wizard does not make a good
decision in the name of protecting harry
dumbledore ignored the poor bloke for an
entire year he claims he did this so
that voldemort wouldn't know they had a
close relationship but i'm pretty
certain that voldemort would have been
aware or at least guessed that
dumbledore had been mentoring the only
wizard prophesied to be the dark lord's
downfall don't you
he allowed dolores umbridge to take up
the defense against the dark arts
teaching position at hogwarts now i know
dumbledore didn't hire her the ministry
did but you'd like to think he could
have done something to stop her from
being a miserable tyrant in her
classroom if he was unable to outright
dismiss her from her role he could have
at least had someone help protect the
children from her abusive teaching
tactics just a thought for some reason
dumbledore asked snape to teach harry
oclamancy he knew this would be a
painful experience for both severus and
harry and yet he still decided snape
would be the best wizard for the job in
my opinion he should have asked someone
else even though he was on the hunt for
voldemort's horcruxes and knew that any
item he found at the house of gaunt
would be quite dangerous indeed when he
laid eyes upon marvolo gaunt's ring
dumuldo put the cursed ring on he didn't
just touch it he picked it up and put it
on
obviously this was the wrong choice on
many levels it was an act that
inevitably led to his death and it was
completely avoidable our final example
of dumbledore being wrong was every
single time he simply didn't trust harry
throughout the entire series he only
shared information with harry in pieces
this of course ranged in degree of
severity with some of the most egregious
omissions relating to topics such as
voldemort's horcruxes snape's true
loyalty the deathly hallows and in my
opinion the most unforgivable harry's
destiny to die
and that brings us to the end of this
video
now if you don't agree with some of
these let me know why in the comments
below but i warn you even dumbledore
himself admitted to being wrong every
once in a while
but you think you're right said harry
naturally i do but as i've already
proven to you i make mistakes like the
next man in fact being forgive me rather
cleverer than most men my mistakes tend
to be correspondingly huger if you
enjoyed this video don't forget to like
it and subscribe to the channel until
next time would you care for a sherbet
lemon
[Music]
you